Now let's look into the details of the
Diffie-Hellman key exchange algorithm.
There are two publicly known numbers,
a prime number Q and
an integer alpha that is
a primitive root of Q.
Now suppose users A and
B wish to exchange a key using the
Diffie-Hellman key exchange algorithm.
User A selects a random integer
XA that's less than q, and
computes you that's raised alpha
to the power of XA and then mod q.
Likewise, User B independently selects
a random integer XB that's less than q,
and then computes YB, that is,
alpha raised to the power of XB and
then mod q.
Each side keeps the X value private and
then sends the Y value
to the other side.
Because the Y value is transmitted,
in effect it is public.
User A upon receiving YB
would compute a key as YB
raised to the power of XA mod q.
This is actually the same
as alpha raised to power of
XB times XA then mod q.
Likewise, User B upon
receiving you computes
a key that is you raised
to the power of XB mod q,
which is the same as alpha raised
to the power of XA times XB mod q.
That is, both sides have,
in effect, computed the same key.
In other words, now User A and
User B have a shared secure key.
Furthermore, XA and XB are private, and
an adversary such as User C only
knows Q and alpha, which are public,
and you and YB, which is transmitted,
and they are also public.
If the attacker wants to
compute the shared key,
he must first compute the X value.
For example,
the attacker must compute the discrete
log of YB in order to get XB.
If the attacker can compute
a discrete log and obtain XB,
he can then compute the shared
secret key by using the you value.
The security of the Diffie-Hellman key
exchange algorithm lies in the fact that
while it's relatively easy to calculate
the exponents modulo a prime,
it is very difficult to
compute a discrete logarithm.
For large primes such as Q
at at least 300 digit long,
this task is considered infeasible.